first down and goal to go at the one the
homes up on the football offset I the
sausage in it full-back they move to the
right side they City Travis Kelce Travis
tells me how does it feel I'll tell you
what baby you feel outstanding Kansas
City we fight it all right the catch
that sparked a 21-point fourth quarter
and then obviously the aftermath of it
the Kansas City Chiefs all-pro tight end
none other than Travis Kelce back here
on the Rich Eisen show for the first
time however as a Super Bowl champion
how are you Travis man I'm living the
dream big guy and I'm living the dream
man I bet you are those all those all
those sounds and sights and sounds just
gave me gave me the chills man I don't
know I don't know what it is about
winning a Super Bowl in Miami man but
that is a that was stuff done well I
mean what what in the hell is it like to
score a touchdown in the Super Bowl
what's that like it's it's it's cool to
reflect on it but at the time it was
like man we need another score I'm not
here to play around and mess around we
need that ball back we need to come down
here score again so at the time it was
just like this one doesn't mean much you
know because it's a I feel like this is
the scoring a touchdown unless you win I
mean the ultimate goal is winning so if
you doesn't matter what you do if you
lose you're you know you're unsuccessful
so I was just focused on getting a win
at that point put me in the huddle on
third and 15 on that Drive Travis where
it seemed like the whole damn Super Bowl
was on line with that next snap walk me
through that what was it like um really
in my mind it's a situational football
it's like we're pretty much in a
territory and the time to getting down
to being almost like a four down
mentality so I was just thinking like
man if we don't get the first year at
least get close enough to where we're
giving ourselves a great shot are given
coach Reid a good opportunity to play
call a play that you know sir fourth and
five is completely different than fourth
and 15 you know so he dials up this play
that we uh we had
I've set it up almost to where Tyree
Kayla had been running across field and
in now you know he hit the the second
the the second play of it which is to go
the opposite way and sure enough I mean
it worked like a charm and it's just an
eerie play Colin
well it's also Holmes throwing and he'll
catch and right I mean how many times
have we seen you guys do this go
vertical when you have to have it or go
vertical to flip a script or go vertical
to spark a run what what it what is it
like - I guess watch that ball go over
your head and know what what might be in
the air Travis I mean it was cool it was
a it's I mean yeah that was that was
probably the play that sparked it for us
and Mike gave us confidence ir yeah now
we're rolling out we got a chance you
know we knew we had the opportunity but
converting a third down to get us into a
Niners territory and E and to get things
rolling with Pat and Tyreke I mean now
they you could feel the momentum kind of
getting on our side and obviously that
was the that was a huge turning point
again but I mean it's a we know we
always got the players we know we always
are gonna have the bright play called
this is going out there and execute man
Travis Kelce here on the Rich Eisen show
all right and another question I got for
you for play call in this game where the
hell did the 1948 Rose Bowl play come
from I know it was BN his idea I guess
but walk walk me through how that got
installed and then called and then used
in a Super Bowl Travis well we got we
got crazy crazy minds in the in the
offensive room and I'm not I'm not just
talking about coaches and players like
going to the statistic guys to the to
the guys or the analytical guys like
everybody everybody that's breaking down
football you know not just our games but
college games recent Super Bowl games
recent you know college bowl games and
they found this play that kind of just
it was it was awkward but it was still a
very good play to run on first down and
sure enough it was in the Rose Bowl
coach Reid being a West Coast guy I
think he had a
I think he had some type of relationship
with this place
we have been running that thing when I
tell you we've been running that thing
which seems to be freaking 11 weeks now
and we just haven't called it in the
game come on there's a perfect time to
call it on force and I think it was one
or two so you've been practicing it for
three months it wasn't just installed
for the Super Bowl like literally and
then you so oh my gosh so a few
different guys I mean you know what it
really was Sammy Watkins couldn't spin
he was having a real hard time spending
without running into the running back so
it was kind of like I we don't want to
go out there look like a bunch of
Schmucks who want Sammy steps on someone
sweating he falls on the ground yeah it
was just trying to figure out when Sammy
could you know finally get the footwork
down and everything with a figured out
how to spin just in time for the Super
Bowl is basically what you're saying you
know what I think I think it was the
atmosphere I taught him a little one two
steps think think left foot first and
then and then right the right now I
thought I had a little bit to do with it
of course a lot of Travis you're a
factor I mean let's be honest I mean
you're a factor in many ways I mean and
then so it's called and you guys look at
each other and go oh my god here we go I
mean what a time to pull that thing out
of the Hat oh my god man just just
enough just enough time for to get a
defender to see what we're doing like
what the heck is this and then ball snap
mmm you know it just gives us that extra
tape to be able to come off the ball and
catch some guys off guard Travis Kelce
here on the Rich Eisen show now I mean I
don't know what I know I want to know
more you know what it's like to be in
the Superbowl and make the plays like
you made and I just walk through that or
what you did personally after the Super
Bowl and party I let's get to that
Travis so games over then what happens
for you give me give me the whole soup
thoughts and when you and then when you
went to sleep literally from the final
snap to when you went to sleep Travis
what happened oh man I am I felt like I
did was a time where I just blacked out
like off of excitement and
everything just kind of bottled up and
it was just it was like a it was like a
you jumped on a slip and slide and
you're just just on it for days it just
feels so unbelievable rush I mean I'm
getting it right now just even thinking
about it it's a it's a cool feeling when
we went down to South Beach went to a
few clubs down there bounced around but
I had about 40 people from back in my
hometown that met me out there and we
ended up finding a spot down there in
Miami mm-hmm
and yeah party till about 10:00 11:00 in
the morning nobody kicked us out I was
surprised I was surprised I think they
tried to they gave me the bill like
three or four times I find it and then
ask them if we can get you know can we
just get one more of those 1942 just one
just one and now I had one turned into
another one and then you know by the end
of the night you you can't really
remember where your pants are but other
than that we found a way to get back to
Kansas City and the parade's gonna be
tomorrow and that's where we're really
pumped up yeah man that is fantastic now
you know Travis with the parade
apparently there's snow coming are you
aware that there's snow coming for your
parade are you down let's go city
doesn't care okay I know I don't care
okay and then bundle up we'll just
bundle up okay grab a twosie and keep it
going
so also also though there there there is
a bar that's been set very high within
your own household as to how to dress
and perform at a challenge Super Bowl
your brother Jason has set the bar very
high showing up to Philly parade in the
mummer's outfit so what do you have
planned
Travis hahaha man I don't know no this
is I'm more nervous about this than I
was the game this is a game what the
game was football at the end of the day
the game line game this speech I mean to
even try it's gonna it's gonna be like
everyone's gonna put it up against my
brother speech like I'm actually
competing with him it doesn't matter
what I said right so it's either I try
and go all out and top what my brother
did or I don't try and
it at all and and just and just throw
the white flag in me in the air right
yeah I guess I mean you know but Eli
never did that with Peyton right I mean
you know the same right Rhonda antiquey
I mean they never did that they you know
I'm just I'm just throwing it out there
Travis that you got 24 hours to just
settle you're right and you're right
you're your thing I gotta I gotta top it
I'm just saying I believe in you is what
I'm saying
that's what I'm saying giving you an
atta boy right here Travis it sounds
like you know you you you partied til
literally passed on you know you you you
you're still working the tequila out of
your system beautiful yeah you're
working the tequila out of your system
still you had your exit visit with Andy
right with Andy Reid correct yeah okay
so the business is taken care of now
you've got time I'm so all I'm saying
you've got time there's some snow
involved let's try and figure it out
let's try and figure it out you know
what yeah I mean if the people are gonna
be out there in the cold like that I
should probably say some fire right well
I mean you also got some Beastie Boys
you can go through their entire music
list you've already didn't give a
full-on Beastie Boys performance to a
point maybe to a point okay monkey
the entire Licensed to Ill album just do
it that's right that's a good one you
could do that for sure alright before I
let you go what was that moment between
you and Andy Reid I mean the whole
country's just and falling head over
heels for your coach in the manner that
you guys clearly already have what was
that moment with you and Andy like
Travis man is some man it's a it was
like it was like we lifted the entire
world off his back man I mean he's
always been himself but to see he'd see
the excitement out of them to see how
you know his his passion for the game
every single day and to see his
excitement when he held up that Lombardi
man that was that was the coolest moment
in my NFL career ever was seeing that
guy you know put that stamp of approval
on and just all the hard work finally
you know paying off of that guy because
I'd know countless kind
days countless weeks that I've seen this
guy's car never moved from from that
parking spot man he's standing up here
however long he has to to just set us up
for an opportunity to succeed and win
this and you know I devote my entire
freakin career that guy I'm so fortunate
I was able to land here in Kansas City
seven years ago and go to war for this
guy every single game where I got to
tell you Travis one day when you show up
in Ohio in in the in the stands watching
him give a speech with a bus - next to
him wearing a yellow jacket a gold
jacket yeah I'm serious I'm serious
it'll be I know you you you helped birth
that with that touchdown in the end zone
and everything that you've done and that
game with mahomes that 21 point
fourth-quarter everything that that that
sealed it as far as I'm concerned you
can know that when you sit I'll stand
with you I thought he was a Hall of
Famer without it and all this did was
just put the stamp of you've made it on
everything man and it was it was ironic
because donovan mcnabb came and spoke to
the team and we had a bunch of speakers
come through coach Jimmy John's a Hall
of Fame coach Jimmy Johnson as well as
Brett Favre both came through when the
donivans message this is the week of the
Super Bowl okay so they came and spoke
at practice a few times Brett came and
spoke the night before but Donovan's
message as you could feel how much it
weighed on him that he couldn't get one
for Andy and he's not the only player
that that's thought that I thought I got
that I've got that feeling from when
they speak about it and it's it's just
uh you could tell how much everyone
loves to play for this guy and how much
everyone loves representing this guy on
the football field and his message
really put it indeed you know what we
got to do I've been saying it this far
man but we really got to go and get it
and the biggest thing that he said was
that you know when Andy wins that we all
win because we're all a part of this
family and that was that was probably
one of the coolest moments I had to be
and then Favre talking to a team before
the Super Bowl I mean come on that's
that's as good as it gets
right there far far as my first football
jersey man so that was that was pretty
surreal that was that was pretty surreal
but I would probably give Jimmie Johnson
the best speech for this award what are
you saying I mean he came in there fired
up had everybody about ready to run
through a window man but he gave he gave
a speech that he said he gave to his
first Super Bowl team when they played
the bills and the bills head I think
like 5 to 10 the Hall of Famer knows how
to just listening names right but um he
said he told his team you know that this
game is just a game and I think people
kind of lose you know the concept of it
at a once you get to the league is that
you know it's still a game think of this
is you put a 2x4 tent like let's say a
ten-foot to bust for on the ground you
walk on the 2x4 it's balanced you know
every human can do it it's a part of any
balanced test that you can take up can
you walk the line and it when it's on
the ground I mean I suspect everybody in
America could probably walk on that
thing no problem but you put it 20 feet
in the air you can use it clutters your
mind it makes you think that you can't
walk on a 2x4 anymore and what that did
was it separated you know what's real at
the end of the day this is going to be a
game we've been playing for the far
entire lives is just going to be a walk
on down the line and that separated how
big this moment was - hey we can do this
you know this isn't this isn't anything
more than what we've been doing our
entire lives we've been doing as a team
all season and let's go out there and do
this thing with confidence so I started
telling everybody on the team let's go
ahead and tap dance on this 2x4 baby go
ahead and dance our way across this
thing man have some fun while we do it
well I'll tell you what it took a while
broke it down like that and it was
beautiful man I had to be and had to be
took a while took you about three and a
half quarters before you got but got
your balance in that 2x4 but once you
did you took it off the ground you hit
the now
over the head with it and that and that
was really something else man for Kansas
City I'm sure you know what it means to
all those fans and everybody in that
great city I have a great time at the
parade I know you're gonna come up with
something big in the next 24 hours I
just feel it and Travis I know it well
I'm gonna have to start brewing up some
ideas all right no pressure no pressure
but if you just show up just have a good
time but that you didn't need to hear
that from me hey man I love you I just
I've loved getting to know you over
these last several years and watch you
you know come out of Cincinnati and
become become what you've become and now
you're a Super Bowl champion I
appreciate you calling in like this as
always you're the man big guy you're the
man you know I've always admired you and
your talent and how you go about your
day man it's uh it's definitely a
pleasure to always jump on and yeah and
I you just got to call me Super Bowl
champion every time you you introduced
me on your show that is a deal that is a
deal we'll see out here in LA in a
couple of weeks whenever you get out of
here so let's set let's start it off
this has been Super Bowl champion Travis
Kelce on the Rich Eisen show how does
that sound
man that sounds sweeter than any song
I've ever heard big guys enjoy the
parade you know it's Travis Kelce right
here on the show for the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 under wreck
TV for free on VR live or download the
Rich Eisen show app
[Music]